I highly doubt big Pharma is going to do
any ads on this video you'll find that
here in a second why look last year 530
000 Americans two-thirds that filed
bankruptcy last year did it because of
medical bills because they can't afford
to pay it anymore so the question
becomes why when you look at the patent
laws that we have in America it's
absolutely catastrophic coming from a
capitalist but we have a solution and we
think our solution no one's thought
about and we'll reveal that to you at
the end we think that could change the
game drastically when it comes on to Big
Pharma save you money make them money
and get everybody to work
[Music]
thank you
okay so if you give Ali out of this
video give it a thumbs up and subscribe
to the channel let's get right into it
here's what we're going to be looking at
we're going to look at what happens when
these Pharma companies have a patent
what happens the year the patent expires
how much does it drop off we'll look at
the top 10 most expensive
Pharmaceuticals in America drugs how
much it costs per year how much money
these guys are making and can we figure
out a way to get everybody to work
together collaborate and still make
billions of dollars and allow to be cost
effective for customers so let's take a
look at this when you look at
pharmaceutical patents today it's 20
years which means if you come out with a
drug that you're able to patent you're
pretty much protected for 20 years in
many cases they're able to patent
multiple times protect them for 40 years
so how do they do it let's take a look
according to iMac the top 12 brand drugs
on the market are protected by a total
of 848 patents that's 71 per drug
providing an average of 38 years without
generic competition the world's top
selling brand drug Humira treats
arthritis and other chronic conditions
on the market since 2 2002 ready 132
patents block competition for up to 39
years which means there's not going to
be any competition until about 2041. one
of the most prescribed Cancer Treatments
revlimited was approved by FD in 2005
the patent Thicket consists of 96
captains providing potentially 40 years
without any competition imagine if you
have products that you can sell this
thing for four years you have no
competition who wins there do the
consumers win what can you charge them
who did takes the price I'm going to
sell it for a thousand bucks but I can't
pay for it too bad nobody else has the
product are you serious but if I don't
take this I'm going to go through XYZ
but if my mom doesn't take this but if
my son doesn't take it too bad it's a
thousand bucks go elsewhere there is no
other place exactly my point pay me my
money you see why sometimes there is
that friction between the companies that
have this kind of patent they get to
hurt the customer let's continue
diabetes patterns will rely on the
insulin treatment lent this may not see
a generic alternative for 37 years due
to 49 patents issued so now we can go
through a lot of different stories I can
give you 20 other stories like this
let's take a look at how these
pharmaceutical companies go go about
extending the pattern past the 20-year
limit that they have number one
evergreening this practice involves
making slight modifications to an
existing drug such as changing its
formulation dosage or delivery method
and then patenting the new version the
company then encourages Healthcare
Providers to prescribe the new version
even though the original drug still may
be effective number two patent term
extension in some jurisdictions
companies can apply for patent firm
extension if they can demonstrate that
they have invested significant time and
resources in developing the drug this
extension is typically granted to
compensate for the time spent in
research and Regulatory approval
processes number three data exclusivity
pharmaceutical companies often receive a
period of data exclusivity during which
they have exclusive rights to the
clinical trial data they've generated
this can delay the entry of generic
drugs into the market as other
manufacturers must wait until the
exclusivity period expires to access the
data and develop their own versions
pretty creative what these guys are
doing right to keep extending another 10
years and 10 years again imagine 40
years no competition but there's four
other ways they do it as well number
four patent clustering companies May
file multiple patents around a single
drug covering various aspects such as
manufacturing processes formulations and
even potential uses five pay for delay
agreements sometimes pharmaceutical
companies enter into agreements with a
generic drug manufacturers to delay the
introduction of a generic version of a
drug in those deals the brand name drug
manufacturers compensates the generic
manufacturers for not launching their
product for a specified period can you
imagine this look we'll give you 50
million bucks just leave it alone we'll
give you 10 million bucks please don't
compete with us that's another way
they're able to extend that next one
orphan drug exclusivity in some cases
drugs developed to treat rare diseases
orphan drugs receive extended Market
exclusivity to encourage companies to
invest in research and development for
these conditions and last but not least
legal challenges pharmaceutical
companies May engage in litigation to
enforce their patents or challenge the
validity of generic competition how can
you do that when you're sitting on all
this cash you can just keep people in
court be litigious scare the crap out of
everybody and be able to extend your pad
few more years you may say Pat these are
our anecdotes give me a break I mean you
show us some data what happens when
these guys lose their patents their
dramatic price drop off the following
year let's take a look what happens deer
when their patent expires what happens
to the price of the drug to follow in
Europe here's some examples for you data
shows prescription drug costs declined
by 90 in some cases when the patent
expires and competition enters the
market it is estimated that generic
entry typically leads to an on average
80 percent market share loss here's an
example Lipitor this is a Pfizer
cholesterol lowering medication the
patent expired in 2011. take a look at
the revenues there blue the dark blue is
U.S light blue is international do you
notice how in 2001 it keeps climbing
2002 three four five they're doing
incredible for themselves but the patent
expires in 2011. look at the drop off
they go from the dark blue which is
roughly little over four and a half
billion dollars in the US they drop to
800 million dollars all the way down to
76 million dollars when others can sell
their product for Pennies on a dollar
and then other consumer says I can't
afford to buy this how many people in
America right now are dealing with high
cholesterol this drug can save a lot of
people's lives but many cannot afford to
pay for it 20-year patent 30-year patent
40 year patent is that a good thing
let's look at another example here
Nexium a drop for gastro reflux disease
okay so the pattern for this expired in
2014 take a look at this here on what
happened to them 2006 7 8 9 10 11 12 13
14 they're doing pretty good look what
happens in 2015 the Euro drops up do you
see that massive drop off from the
revenues 3.6 billion down to two and a
half billion all of a sudden it goes to
1.2 billion that's a 75 discount 70
discount simply by allowing the market
to compete for this so now some people
capitalists may say Pat but if that
confidence doesn't come out with that
patent nobody else has it I totally get
it I have a solution for but let's look
at one other example here let's take a
look at the next one here seraquel it's
a prescription for schizophrenia and
bipolar disorder the patent expires in
2012. before I even show you the numbers
I want to prepare you you're going to be
Shell Shocked okay you're going to shell
shot see how their numbers look from
2006 to 2011 2006 3.4 billion then they
go to 4 billion 4.4 billion 4.8 billion
5.3 billion 2011 they do 5.8 billion
dollars patent expires next year they
drop off to 2.8 billion 1.6 billion
eventually in 2021 it ends up becoming
92 million you know what the savings is
and how much it dropped off from 5.8
billion to 92 Million ready 98 and a
half percent drop off let me say this
one more time 98 and a half percent drop
off I'm selling this drug to you for a
thousand dollars versus now it's not 98
is 9.85 that's the equivalent of what
just happened there because of patent
expired this is the kind of stuff that
frustrates a lot of different people
matter of fact let's take a look at the
top 10 most expensive drugs in America
today take a look at this so first I
want to butcher some of these names so
breaks for impact but let's take a look
at this top 10 number one zogin's month
2.125 million dollars per year for a
course of treatment and this is to treat
spinal muscular atrophy a rare childhood
disorder folks 2.1 million dollars per
year number two zokinvi one million
seventy three thousand dollars this is
treatment for Hutchinson Guilford
progaria syndrome a rare genetic disease
that causes premature aging number three
danielsa one million eleven thousand
dollars per year this is to treat
neuroblastoma in the bone or bone marrow
pediatric and adult patients number four
chemtrac 975 per year this is to treat
metastatic or surgically untreatable
uvial melanoma a form of eye cancer
number five Maya lab 929 000 a year this
is to treat leptin deficiency in
patients with generalized lipodystrophy
which causes abnormal fat distribution
in the body number six looks Turner 850
per year this is a gene therapy that
treats an inherited form of retinol
dystrophy a condition that causes vision
loss and often even complete blindness
number seven Fullerton 842 dollars per
year this is to cure a rare blood cancer
that can cause death number eight renura
this helps treat the slow loss of
walking ability in pediatric patients
three years and older number nine blind
Sito 754 000 per year it is used to
treat a rare form of acute lymphoblastic
leukemia cancer of the blood and bone
marrow number 10 River City 695 000 per
year it is used to treat urea cycle
disorders and if it's left untreated
they can lead to confusion coma or even
deaths keep this in mind I'm recognizing
all the scientists and doctors and
pharmaceutical companies that invented
this they ought to get credit for
getting it and I do believe they deserve
to have a patent because that's the part
of the incentive but 20 years and then
extending another 20 years that's when
you know you're not doing good for
society so how do these laws go into
effect well first one was in 1790 and
this is during the George Washington era
of being a president the patent Act of
1790 this was a first patent statue
enacted in the United States established
the basic framework of grand painting
patterns and protect inventors rights
which later extended to the
pharmaceutical industry this leads to
1984 hatch and Waxman act Senator Orrin
Hatch from Utah Republican and
Congressman Harry Waxman from California
Democrat came together and said this 20
years is too long can we bring it down
to 14 years that's what they did they
passed it to 14 years doll concept
behind this was as a pathway for generic
drugs to come to Market more quickly and
at a lower cost so good they helped save
six years great consumers one here so
how long did that last 14 years only 10
years because in 1994 you got in trips
Gat stands for General agreement of
tariffs and trade and trips stand for
trade related aspects of intellectual
property rights they raised it back up
to 20 years and the law was implemented
in 1995. so Pat again is did this really
increase prices let's take a look at
history since 1980. so 1980 to today
prices have nearly 8xed this chart here
shows it's
2016-2017. it's nearly 8X if you look at
1985 4 the hatch Waxman act which
lowered it to 14 years there wasn't
really a major spike in per capita
spending on retail prescription drugs
but if you look at 1994 Gat and trips
act look what happens afterwards boom
skyrocketed pharmaceutical companies
started competing even more because now
they can extend it from 14 years to 20
years and Beyond so before I give you my
solution on what I think they can do
here let me kind of give you both sides
of the argument the guys that said well
we should keep it 20 years there's
nothing wrong with 40 years this is
actually good and the ones that are
saying listen this is insane why are we
doing it this long here's those that are
saying it is good to have a long patent
this is their argument number one
incentivizing Innovations fine number
two promoting drug access and
availability Fair number three
protecting intellectual property rights
great those are three points that you
have now let's look at against it here's
what the arguments are number one high
drug prices and access barriers two
monopolistic practices and lack of
competition agree number three limited
Innovation and repurposing number four
4. publicly funded research and
development and number five ethical
consideration so now some people say Pat
this is crazy that I'm looking at the
drop off what happens after the patent
who can do anything about it Congress
the way you vote and the next president
why don't they talk about it as much
here's why most lobbyists these
mainstream media companies get tens if
not hundreds of millions of dollars
every year from Big Pharma because
remember there's only two countries in
the world that allows pharmaceutical
companies to advertise on TV us is one
of them and I believe New Zealand passed
an act in 1980 that allowed him to do it
as well all the other 200 plus countries
worldwide do not allow this because it's
ridiculous to be doing something like
this right so why don't more people talk
about this because they're not going to
get political campaign contributions and
a lot of these guys are not going to put
them on TV to host them because their
enemy that they're going after is the
one that's funding their companies many
cases but let's not be that skeptical
let me give you my idea so you know the
whole concern is like let's put 20 years
and let's not allow all the other us to
do anything else this is ridiculous let
us protect our patent we came out with
this product what if we did this what if
you who come out with the patent no
problem you got five years go you're on
the market do whatever you want to do
with the price dictate the price we
don't agree with it but thank you for
creating a drug like this that's saving
a lot of people's lives go ahead and do
it but guess what five years from now
you can lease your patent to any other
company and they get to sell it at any
price that they want to but you get 10
percent for whatever they sell it for
for 15 years what does this mean let's
say you're selling this drug for a
thousand dollars okay for five years you
can sell it for a thousand dollars I'm
just giving a number to make it easy
five years later 20 other people come in
and say hey we want to sell that drug as
well here's a 15-year lease total 20
years everything you sell it for you got
to give me ten percent but we want to
sell it for 200 bucks no problem sell it
for 200 bucks per one you sell I get 20
bucks the company well that's not good
because weren't they making a thousand
dollars now you expect them to be okay
for some you for 200 yeah but now if 20
other companies do it 20 companies are
not selling that drug at 200 you're
making ten percent on 20 companies
selling it on 200 and maybe you're gonna
have to lower your prices as well now
you're sitting there saying I'm okay
with that they're doing the work they're
doing all that stuff I'm making the
money on that letter rib I'll make
additional money for 15 years meaning
every other company becomes my
distributor this is fantastic they do it
as they do everything I make 10 yes I'm
all in and you get credit for the patent
for 20 years 20 years later it's off you
don't make the 10 everybody else can go
sell it rather than what the government
did to come in and say insulin you know
medication it's capped at 35 that's
hurting that's regulation that's you
telling me how to run my business that's
you telling me what price point to put
it at versus let free market and
consumers dictate what's the right
number you win I win the companies win
the innovators win everybody goes home
happy if you got value out of this video
give it a thumbs up subscribe to the
channel if you got another idea you're
thinking I was doing a completely
different way send me a tweet at
patrickbetdavid uh and I want to hear
your thoughts if you got better ideas
than this then I got another video I did
five years ago October of 2018 title why
I love capitalism 10 reasons why I love
capitalism if you've never seen it some
of you guys are watching and saying wait
a minute I'm confused first you're going
after the capitalist and an example like
this now you're saying this is why you
love capitalism exactly wait till you
find out why if you've never seen that
video click here to watch it take care
everybody bye-bye